[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
needle in a haystack
detecting low levels of viral rna in
plant tissues
i'm christy doula flabberts and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by biosearch technologies
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit biosearchtech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click submit
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also use the ask a question box
to let us know if you're having any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
in addition to asking questions we
encourage you to participate in the
three polls we have today throughout our
presentation
just click on your answer when the poll
questions are displayed
in fact let's start with our first poll
now today is world backup day
how do you back up your files
either select external hard drive
usb or sd card
cloud storage
other
or none
we'll go ahead and give you a few
moments to choose your answer
again how do you backup your files
external hard drives usb or sd card
cloud storage
other
or none
thank you so much for your participation
and with that i would like to now
welcome our speaker for today's webinar
dr amit singra
founder and cso of nupi incorporated
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome dr dangra you may now begin your
presentation
thank you christy for that introduction
and also thank the organizers and
biosearch technologies for this
opportunity to share
our research
i am the founder and chief science
officer of new phi inc
it's a company that i spun out of my
program research program at washington
state university
back in 2011 it's gone through a couple
of changes to now become new phi
and
i've recently moved to texas a m
as professor and department head
since last year fall
and my program is in the areas of
genomics and biotechnology i work in the
area of horticultural crops high value
specialty crops
where there are some challenges that
we've been working on in our research
and as we developed
as we developed all the technologies we
wanted to bring it to the
to the industry to the horticultural
industry in washington across the u.s
and what i'm going to share today is
kind of walk you through some of the
problems we've had and what we're
working in this space we are able to
collaborate with um
companies such as biosearch technologies
and there are opportunities to develop
new solutions for the industry
so with that uh you're probably all
familiar with some of the challenges we
currently face as a planet
we are going to be feeding a larger
population in the next 30 years and
that's not too far away
we're looking
at our own children grandchildren maybe
some of us in the in the audience who
are going to be you know in their middle
ages by that time so this is a reality
facing us very closely
and uh according to some estimates we
are losing about 30 soccer fields worth
of arable productive agricultural land
per minute
not only due to urbanization which is
fine but also due to deteriorating soil
conditions
over fertilization fertilizer use as
well and then uh finally
a lot of the current agricultural
practices um
really cause a lot of carbon issue or
carbon loss which is also
impacting negatively impacting soil
health and overall climate issues so
while with this backdrop is what you
know in a way we we kind of work at new
phi we are addressing some of these
global challenges
and just to introduce briefly about new
phy there are three sectors to the to
the uh technology platform we have the
first one is the validation piece where
horticultural growers or industry
growers
are uh they need clean true type
genetically prototype plant material all
the time
while it is
sort of a luxury in case of crops row
crops some of these technologies or some
of these quality standards are not
currently available to the growers
depending on which sector you go to
sometimes as an analogy i kind of talk
simply as you may have planted red
apples but some of those trees turn out
to bear green apples and that can be
costly or there might be some diseases
there that necessitate wiping out the
whole process
so we have robotics in there in fact we
have a lgc genomics platform where we
utilize
uh which we utilize in our system uh we
are utilizing both dna and rna-based
approaches to
ban sequencing based approaches to
screen for diseases the next part is the
propagation part where we we have
utilized a lot of the trade secreted
trademark processes to create healthy
uniform prototype plant materials
and we've already planted about 1.6
million trees in in the ground with a
lot of farmers they perform very well
and finally the full life cycle part of
the ag tech sector what do you do with
all the biomass and we recently acquired
a company to
which
forms the regeneration part of the
system where we can take the biomass
and convert it into a consistent quality
biochar that not only sequesters carbon
but also can produce energy
so the idea is that we produce better
soils
better plants with good yields and
eventually it leads to better
profitability and sustainability for the
farmers so this is a full life cycle
like tech company has evolved into that
today i'm going to focus on the key part
propagation part but it the underlying
piece of that is the validation piece
and that is where this this technology
is
as you learn from the title neil in a
haystack we are looking for plant
viruses and verowites
which can be present at very
different levels of titer or different
number of molecules
in a plant tissue depending on the plant
tissue now some of these crops are not
um
vegetatively active throughout the year
they go through dormancy they go through
different developmental stages where
leaves are shed
flowering happens so there are various
parts of the life cycle when these needs
to be tested
and there's the other aspect of
producing nursery trees
as well you know
developing the trees and these trees are
not growing on their own roots some of
the some of you might like a
apple like cosmic crisp or honey crisp
or royal gala these varieties don't grow
on their own roots they have to be
grafted onto other genetics
and if there are viruses or other
diseases in that the whole tree can die
and there have been major losses in the
industry in the horticultural industry
because of viruses
globally it's it's the the economic
value of viruses is up to 60 billion
dollars per year
they can cause major losses
so how did we come to
developing methodology in this process
so
let me explain what new file really got
started with and to to illustrate that i
would like to point your attention to
the top panel
where that is the traditional method of
producing say an apple tree
what you see in the first box on the
left corner is the
stool bed production of root stocks
where in it can take up to four to five
years to produce a large number of root
stocks
after that these root stocks are
harvested
they are
replanted and then in the second point
around the year six or seven
they are grafted with the cyan variety
they are allowed to grow for a couple of
years uprooted one more time
replanted and unorchard and then you can
see that it can take the whole journey
can take up to 12 to 13 years
by the time that tree
can bear fruit to its full capacity
when we were starting to do this work in
2006 2007 at my program at washington
state university
i started working with a lot of my uh
colleagues who breed rootstocks
notably dr
general fazio at cornell university
as well as a lot of the nursery men
around in the pacific northwest of the
us
and their question was can you develop a
methodology where we never have to
uproot the plants
so basically create a methodology that
will uh go from directly from a
situation where you're not going in the
ground but directly
into the ground to establish the orchard
so that is where this trademark
technology multiply was born the the
lower panel illustrates what that it
looks like i'll elaborate that in a
second but what is multiply is a
confluence of multiple quality control
points
where we produce
a genetically confirmed prototype
disease and virus-free plants a
utilizing an in vitro a combination of
in vitro tissue culture-based
propagation
with optimized media growth media for
the genetic background we're working
with
as well as with combining that with
greenhouse production to then produce
trees that can go directly into the
orchard so whenever we uproot a plant
we're exposing the roots we are damaging
the roots to diseases so there are a lot
of challenges that can come along with
that so this methodology this approach
gets rid of that to go deeper into this
multiply technology
there is there are these few stages
because of the
the flexibility and
the ability to produce large number of
plants in a very small time without
causing any damage this process can be
scaled up very easily
we can get we can make one plant turn
into three to ten plants within about
four weeks time so this is a very good
platform to
amplify
any of the genetic stock once working
with and then
depending on the needs on the right part
of the panel depending on the need of
the industry if they want just the root
stock
or a grafted plant material one can
really easily produce the plant two
specifications in a greenhouse and
deliver to the
industry so this is the process but
before we started doing the work uh
before we got into the picture i was
getting a lot of this uh
outreach from the industry
to make sure that the plants are
prototyped they would ask me questions
at my research lab and we had just
started sequencing the apple genome and
since we have done
pear genome cherry genome and other
crops now we are able to utilize that
high quality genomic data genomic
information to develop a platform to
develop bioassays dna based assays to
conform true to tightness
now one of the challenges in this
process is how do you ensure everything
is disease free
so to start off this process we get the
material from the uh national clean
plant network
uh they provide true they basically
provide clean plaque material this is
virus free certified material
and it is also known very commonly that
whenever you get wireless free certified
clean material
it will not always stay like that and
there are two reasons for that
one of the key reasons is that when it's
planted out in the orchard it can get
reinfected
alternatively which
i don't know the incidence of that but
alternatively the tighter of the viral
particles were so low to begin with that
it was below the detection limit so what
came out as clean in an elisa based
assay or in an rtpcr-based assay may
have missed the low title and this is a
very well known challenge
in virus detection
and this is a very important industry
the horticultural industry is very
important it's it's very highly valued
so this approach to develop a highly
sensitive
a method that is highly sensitive that
can detect very low or extremely low
levels of viruses is very important and
globally the
market that we're addressing is in
billions of dollars
a 7.8 billion dollar market for the
horticultural products
and today i'm going to speak a little
bit about one particular crop but i
wanted to
say that these high-value fruit crops
are highly nutritious
they are also perennial crops so you
don't have to replant so
naturally to a great extent they are
sustainable in approach
and they provide not only calories but
nutrition for a population we want to
support as we go further so today's case
study is based on detecting viruses
in a crop that is
delicious that is
that is really liked all over the world
however it is facing a serious epidemic
because of the coronavirus we are
familiar with the term pandemic
epidemic is when a particular region is
affected pretty badly
and
this disease is called as very little
cherry disease
it's caused by a virus as well as a
disease x phytoplasma
and the industry has had major losses
because the cherry is sour it remains
small because of the viruses
and it really uh destroys the trees
completely so it's a real challenge that
we're facing and today's uh
today's technology that we are utilizing
or the the commercial testing available
is based on
either elisa testing which is
detecting that the
the
protein that is coming from the viruses
alternatively it's rt reverse
transcription pcr
basically detecting the rna because most
of the plant viruses that are pathogenic
have a rna
genome so these are the two
methodologies but they obviously have
their limitations but before i continue
further i wanted to
bring on christy
for a poll
let's see over to you
yes thank you dr denga that does bring
us to our next pool
and here we are what is your current
method for virus detection
elisa
grow outs
rt isothermal amplification
rt qpcr pcr
ngs sequencing
or other
just click on your answer what is your
current method for virus detection
is it elisa
grow out
rt isothermal amplification
rtp rtqpcr pcr
ngs sequencing
or other
thanks for your participation back over
to you dr dinga
thank you see
so uh i wanted to kind of highlight a
point here on that point that i was
making earlier i elaborate on the point
i was talking earlier about the various
types of tests and as you just heard in
the poll there are various methods to do
that
um there is obviously the sequencing
based methodology
rtpcr and elisa are the most common uh
tests
and we are a new file is in particular
certified
uh by the
washington tree fruit research labs to
be able to provide rtpcr based tests to
evaluate the little cherry virus
detection that they do
and in the last year itself we got one
client provided about 1200 samples so
it's a very big need
and one of the challenges with rdpcr is
the throughput you can still do about 10
samples per assay per run but as you can
imagine it's a it's a massive
effort sometimes you can use robotics in
the process however
the other challenge that does remain in
that case is tighter how much can you
detect at what level the detection stops
of course i lie size one at a time you
can do
reader plates but it is really
challenging
um the alternative what that we've been
evaluating is utilizing rna-seq
approaches
uh which of course gen which allows us
to test depending on what platform we
use we usually use illumina platform
we can do up to 500 samples in one go
at a time
and you generate a huge amount of data
set but what rna-seq also allows you to
do now is to do multiplexing you can
basically do field level testing which
is just impossible
cost-wise prohibitive with rdpcr and
vice
now
the big part is that
for rtpcr and elisa as you're familiar
you can only detect what you're testing
for
lysas will allow you to only detect for
which you have antibodies for rdpcr is
limited by the primers you use uh to
detect the viruses and that creates its
own challenges in annealing etc the cool
part of rna sequencing is
it doesn't discriminate if there's a
disease pathogen it can detect very
easily
and the sensitivity is very high as well
in the process now
the challenge with rna-seq which is
where we started collaborating with lgc
uh is that we were really interested in
finding out is there a way
to bring down the cost
and where we worked with the lgc
scientists was to develop a platform
where we can do target enrichment
for rna-seq we removed the ribosomal rna
but there is all that plant rna that is
already there as well
so the idea was can we utilize a
platform
to enrich the target viral particles
and in our conversation they they
introduced us to the
uh hybrid capture technology or hype cap
for sure and let me introduce that to
you briefly uh you may be aware of this
but let me walk through this process
so the high cap technology is where you
make a cdna library
and then you denature it you incubate
that with the probes that you've
developed for
the viruses or a set of disease
pathogens so i just want to step back
briefly on this part and mention that
we
scientists in our group
dr hewitt i will introduce later
acknowledge later
she basically brought all the known
pathogenic viruses database to the table
and then devised a program along with
the help from the lgc scientists to
create overlappings overlapping set of
probes
which would then cover capture the
entire genomes of the viruses that exist
out there but this could be
scaled up to include bacteria bacterial
fungal
because everything does produce rna so
the idea was that if we made a total cd
in the library we can capture everything
and by utilizing standard technologies
we can really enrich the uh process so
you can add
uh magnetic capture beach to the system
because some of your probes have this
biotimiliated ends and by doing that you
can truly enrich the target our goal for
doing this work
is to increase the throughput even more
but reduce the cost uh at where it
becomes extremely affordable
we started this project not too long ago
with lgc and due to all the value chain
limitations and short charges and
supplies we haven't really reached the
end of everything but we've started
doing some work already and i wanted to
share with you some of the approaches we
were planning to take
so what you see in this slide deck is
the uh sort of the plan the research
plan we are looking at
where we are comparing both verified
healthy tissues to infected tissues
and we were going we are doing rna
extractions from both sides and then
creating sequencing libraries
uh where we would uh utilize the hype
cap
approach or the multiplex indexed
approach or just directly library so we
are comparing the hype cap
approach in this process
our expectation is that due to target
enrichment we deplete a majority of the
plant rna as well thereby we could go
from 500 samples per run
or to about 5 000 or even 10 000 samples
per run which gives us the throughput
that we need to really address the needs
of the industry
so um
further this is sort of another
experimental design
where we are looking at
beyond just sweet cherry we are looking
at apples and pears as well because all
crops are infected can be infected
where we are going to be doing a lot of
the hype cap enrichment doing rna-seq
and then thereby assembling and mapping
it to find the the virus viral load so
far
um we've been only able to generate the
rna-seq data separately without the hype
cap enrichment just yet but we have some
proof of concept
where when we use the hive cap probes
recall that hypecap probes are to be
used on cdna library
we were actually able to utilize this
directly on rna and see some very good
data as well
the data are messy so they're not being
presented here but uh we we saw some
potential so obviously we are starting
to see that we can definitely enrich
uh the rna itself as well
and the target rnas
one other thing we did we want to do in
this particular case is look at
different tissues i was mentioning
previously these are temperate crops
they go through different life cycles of
dormancy
and what would be an ideal place to test
for our viruses
the best place would be before
the plant is actively growing in the
spring
and if it's infected it can spread the
virus load pretty quickly
through insects or through bad clippers
so the idea would be could we go and
evaluate
the viral load in different tissues that
would include leaf tissue but mid-ribs
or even bark tissue
if we can use that approach in that
particular case so i wanted to just
share some outcomes of our recent
sequencing run
that
we looked at so what you see in this
slide are three different uh
sequencing reads three different samples
or treatments the top one is the bark
leaf at the middle and midriff mid rib
cast bottom
what you are seeing over here is the
detection limits
with with the leaf system
if we dilute the known amount of tire
below
500
500 x we stop detecting with rtq pcr but
with sequencing we are able to detect
all these viral particles or sequences
transcripts in particular in these
regions as you can expect in a leaf we
definitely get a lot of reads a good
read depth and that's expected because
virus is actively multiplying same for
midrib but what is exciting is that we
can also detect it in the bar tissue so
depend irrespective of the season it
allows us to go
and provide this
service platform to the farmers where
they can detect the viruses that are
infecting the plant material
ahead of time so rather than being
reactive
a farmer can be proactive and cull or
remove those trees and retain the health
of the
other plants that are healthy in the
orchard so this is a really a good
step forward and we expect that with
especially in the bar tissue hype cap
technology can really help us detect
improve our detection limits when we
combine it with sequencing
uh some of the the next slide shows you
some of the viruses um that are there we
knew that
these samples were infected with the
viruses that are depicted in green in
different tissues what is really
interesting is the
viruses that we did not expect to see
which are labeled in yellow so rna
spares no one if it's present it'll be
shown and this is where the power of
combining the height cap but the
sequencing based approach can be very
effective and informative so we are
utilizing this platform right now to
develop this approach utilizing the lgc
platform that we have the intellicube
that we have to be able to provide this
field level testing of pathogens
where we can detect very low level titer
of the plant material as well
so i'd like to conclude
this
presentation by sharing that rna-seq is
indeed the most sensitive method with
the highest limit of detection
at present though rna-seq is a costly
proposition for the
customer and our expectation is that
with lgc hypecap platform it will really
help us increase both the throughput and
then lower the cost per sample so that
we can provide the services to the
farmers who are
struggling to keep their trees alive and
maintain their profitability
of course if none of this would be
possible so with without the support
that we've received from the partnership
between
bioresearch technology or lgc and we've
we've been uh collaborating with clean
plant center northwest i would like to
acknowledge dr scott harper for his
collaboration
we have been partially supported in this
approach by usdsbir grants
as well as the wsda
nursery grant as well so with that i
would like to thank you very much for
this opportunity to share some of our
work and i'll pass it back on to christy
thank you and i'll open it up for any
questions
thank you dr dingra that was an
excellent presentation and you're
correct we will now start the live q a
portion of our webinar now to our
audience if they have a question they
would like to ask please do so now just
type that question into the ask a
question box and click submit we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for but real quick before we
jump into our first question let's bring
up our final poll here
and do you currently use ngs
yes or no
love your input here so please um let us
know if you are currently using ngf yes
or no
okay
dr dengra let's start with our very
first question and we have quite a few
coming in
does new fly have any plans to expand
the offering to other high-value
horticultural crops such as flowers or
potentially even into fruits and
vegetables
yes that's an excellent question and you
know um
as you've kind of noted we are already
expanding beyond cherry to other fruit
crops
this
next generation sequencing based
is of course agnostic of what plant
material we use
so
indeed our goal is to provide the
service to the industry
and
as long as we can isolate good quality
rna from there i don't see any
limitations
the good part is that there are about 2
400
known pathogenic viruses
and we already have probes
prepared for all of them
so
as we
expand these services
it could be really provided to the
entire industry
thank you
thank you the next question
how simple is it to add new pathogens to
the existing panel
and how long would it take to validate
utility of the platform for detection of
a new pathogen or virus
that's great as well i kind of answered
the first part of the question you know
we have
uh for example for viruses i added the
address the question we basically just
need to
uh we already have the probes or all the
viruses
uh the
the design part for new probes is pretty
straightforward
obviously we have to go through some a
quality control in that ensure that the
probes are covering the genome there are
a couple of approaches to ensure that
each part of the pathogen genome is
covered
now if you get into bacterial and fungal
pathogens those genomes are larger so
one might go selective on certain
regions that are more
shared between different pathogens or
unique depending on what we're looking
for so it's creating a library
and the validation part is
what that involves is performing initial
rtpcr based detection and tissues where
we know that the pathogen is very well
replicated replicating so or or present
so these are
technologically
uh not challenging in that context it's
just developing that protocol and being
able to
be able to do it consistently and i
think that's where
having a robotics platform is easier
once we've established standardize a
process it's plug and play at that point
dr dengra how does the limit of
sensitivity lod compare to other methods
like qrt pcr or elisa
yeah i had this in my table but i can uh
you know qrt pcr is obviously more
sensitive than eliza
elisa has another challenge it can have
cross reactivity with non-specific
targets
and so can qrt pcr when you use primers
you can amplify something else so just
seeing a result
uh just seeing amplification in a qrt
pcr reaction
or a ban on a gel
is not enough you must confirm it
sometimes as well um
we have done where we added a known
amount of titer of wireless particles to
a tissue
we diluted it one is to 500 times
and at that 500 dilution limit the
qrt pcr became ineffective however the
sequencing
still worked so it seems like sequencing
would be able to detect even a few
molecules
off if there is transcript being made
we can detect it so i think that's uh
elisa is probably even like
it probably stops at one is to 10
dilution of that particular uh virus and
when i say one
the one is
also uh you know we're using a few
picograms of the tyre
uh
of the
initial
reference genome or reference molecule
of or a viral particle so it's it's very
clear that
ngs
is high the most sensitive platform
available
thank you dr gingra what crop do you see
as the most challenging to test and why
um i do want to compliment the audience
they have very good questions
so
let me want to say that
i don't see a challenge with the crop i
think the challenge would be with the
tissue we work with
uh the limitation we can isolate rna
from leaf material from almost anything
by utilizing various methods
one can overcome rna isolation
challenges from leaf tissue
from any type of crop
i think the challenge would be can we go
to the difficult you know area different
difficult tissues like just exam as an
example the bar tissue
where we were able to isolate rna that
would be the more challenging part for
us
thank you and we have time for a few
more questions
how important are the sample preparation
methods prior to running on your
detection platform
and how can you and how do you assess
sample integrity
thinking about
rna degradation
etc yeah absolutely i think you've kind
of
almost answered the question
we have to have high quality rna and our
scientists in the lab definitely spend a
lot of time in ensuring the highest
quality rna to begin with
some of the tissues that's where the
it's also alludes to the previous
question that you're asked what crop
would be difficult that's where some of
the tissues can be difficult for example
if we have to
isolate rna from root tissue which is in
the soil that can create some challenges
as well so
uh making sure that the the you know the
rna
sort of integrity values
rin is one way to look at it is is
perfect we actually use multiple
methodologies we do rin methodology of
course but we also always
test off some of these sample rnas
randomly on a gel going back to old
school making sure the quality and
integrity of the rna is good it's uh
utilizing at least two forms of quality
control before we jump to the next level
uh sometimes uh when we i also want to
put in a plug for high cap even if there
is some degradation because of the
specificity that we can obtain from hype
cap
i i'm thinking as i'm answering this
question maybe we are able to capture
the rna particles even in subs some uh
you know lower quality rna that needs to
be tested so that'll be an interesting
uh
idea that just emerged from this
question so thanks to the person who
asked the question
and thank you it looks like we have time
for one more question we'll wrap with
this one
what is the current sample throughput in
turn around time for testing at new phi
and do you have any expansion plans
and subway on that is if so how do those
affect the numbers
yeah um well i think the currently what
we are offering and what the industry
standard is which is affordable is the
rtqpcr or tpcr
test we are doing about uh you know 2
000 to 3 000 samples a month
and we definitely have expansion plans
and that's why we are going to this
better technology highly sensitive
technology
and with the um intellicube
as well as the robotics available to us
i think uh i've heard
from my team numbers from 11 000 to 30
000 samples per month
so we definitely want to
expand this offering to a larger set of
industry we want to bring in the what we
call the platinum standard
in disease testing so that the farmer is
you know stress-free
that and there's no doubt in their mind
that what they're planting is clean and
prototype
thank you dr gingrich do you have any
final comments for our audience
well if uh if there are any questions or
if anybody would like to follow up or if
they have more ideas because we are at
the core we are a science driven company
we love to collaborate and we love to
bring in more ideas together so
would be very much interested in having
a conversation
thank you for this opportunity to
present our work
and thank you for your time today and
for your important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor biosearch technologies for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i do want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time to get to
today and additionally those submitted
during the on-demand period they will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
today's webcast can be viewed on demand
and lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
thank you for joining us we hope you
have a great day
you